let's get down to it I was shocked here
you have a big movie career you're a
good-looking guy you have it all going
on so I don't know what led up to this
but I read in the paper you were nude
perhaps intoxicated oh I had a beer
right or two you were naked you were
playing the bongos yes again and a guy
was there yet he was closed right now
first of all first of all no just if
you'll never read about this happening
or just a candle it's good you're weak
this was the weekend yeah you're a big
star you can't go to a lot of places
without being noticed so you probably
spend you probably spend a lot of time
at home right yeah obviously the night
ends there all right where were you that
night to retrace your steps as best you
can at a day go ahead
this all happened Monday morning 237 in
the a.m. so your weekend extended it
could start with Saturday take us
through your week Saturday University of
Texas Longhorns beat Nebraska and you
were obviously a big Texas fan home that
was a big game you an athlete yourself
do you place an athlete you're a decent
outfit okay I can see it carries over in
the Sun right you were celebrating and
drinking we're playing celebrating on
smoking weed Street you go down to sixth
Street no weed streets no weed weed or
coke involved yet no no leader coke Joe
sugg just drinking I'll keep you a try
to keep it pretty natural all right good
no coach it's no Hampton one of those
hemp guys okay right all right so you
having a party
nothing wrong with anyway Sunday now
that Sunday goes long where we do I
don't remember exactly what we did
Sunday we went out we watched him foe
yet we watched some NFL football I think
and that drinking wasn't down
I don't think so yet okay say yes who do
you watch football it who's over your
house mmm but it was actually Malenko we
went down to sixth Street which this is
a regular guy not a movie star he's an
actor he's an actor okay so you think
around when I met on dazed and confused
which all the first great film I did
very good
we went out that night we heard there's
some live music with jam too
Sunday night live music Austin love
music I renounced it's a great live
music town yes of course yeah so any
night of the week you can go find live
music oh there we go Jim some live music
the nikon in it came back to the house
took a cab back and all your clothes are
on and you're drunk that's completely
clothes right this is like late October
now as well I've got a house here's how
here's on my house to set up it's a very
small place but I've got it in one big
room so my bedroom is in the middle of
the room my beds in the middle the room
the living room the couch in the same
room right my office and my desk or just
to the right in my bed and the kitchen
is right there too so I've got it all in
one I like it where it's all in the same
room right everything goes on in that
room a ranch-style house I don't like
going to got to go through the door I
mean right it's all one yeah so then
what do you do you got in the house and
you removed your clothing not a plan
alright get home I love getting on
playing music at night right put on so
what are we listening to on read to
Kanye at the time you should be speaks
French very very nice it's a really nice
groove in this house of yours which is
like one big room so let me see when you
make a doodie don't all your friends
hear it I mean won't you want to
separate airport hangar you know that's
one that's the house right so you get
home I get on put on to music start
jamming and I go and actually and
actually the good story shades Congo's
conquers all right that's a little less
about using your clothes yeah so it's
beautiful night in Austin we're like 68
degrees I've got all the I've got the
screen doors so they open up and two
nights before I had opened up these two
back windows cuz I got this mid night
blooming Jasmine in the backyard right
I'm smelling
it's a whole vibe yeah yeah so I had
opened him up two nights before and shut
the shutters though
yeah the blinds and that's the neighbors
I don't know back there right and you
didn't realize the windows were open the
music was very loud music's loud and I'm
and I'm hung I'm head down and my heads
down into the Gaga's well why the
clothes off somewhere somewhere in there
as you're playing but the guy is there
aren't you gonna like be like why be
naked in front of your friends well
isn't you know what it's not something I
really thought about really you should
think about those now you don't go um
where's my buddy did your buddy think it
was weird that you were naked playing
the car come on you got to admit if you
all were some guy's house and he starts
taking off his clothes and he's running
on naked playing the congas what would
you think series naked playing any kind
of music or naked in general you got I
mean it just feels better
often evening 68 degrees full moon that
night too it feels good
okay so good news though so when your
neighbors called the police
yeah and I'm not even I don't know what
your buddy was thinking that you're
running around naked while he has his
clothes on him forget all that
the police come and here they find
Matthew McConaughey movie star yeah I
mean it sounds like you were really
bombed and also Jama but you were really
high right nothing spectacular I've had
bigger bigger week really trying to get
his attention and he's so into the music
and they can't even get his attention
really get your attention
I'm head down with a banging on the door
or I mean I tell you what bang it on the
door that
or they weren't banging - you don't know
what happened now when the cops cuts
when the cops the cops come to the door
they're banging and you can't even hear
them well and so that's why I still
question well how how loud the bang was
okay so anyway first thing I know is I'm
playing and you see me since someone's
there and you look up and I saw that
it's two silhouettes and you see it's
pretty you can pretty well make out a
cop's uniform - right and my first my
first reaction is what the hell someone
doing in my house nervous not music no
I'm getting pissed first yeah I'm gonna
get the hell out of my house as I turned
down the music and bone man to do that
he flashed it a light over on the coffee
table in my Caesar sees a bong and that
kind of sent them off in a flash
flashlight bag on me and next thing I
knew I'm against the wall and I've got
cuffs on
I very much oh yeah yeah my house taking
my own business you got a BA I think
everyone should well it was no big deal
I mean you were you weren't hurting
anybody there's no harm being done it
was a little difficult getting you in
the car she saw a barn down to the
station house naked did they drag you
down there yeah I would never want to
arrested a naked guy
Maji got Matthew but got him naked in
the dragon are you your neighbors for
this for you know what I like I said I
should shut the back to Windows I didn't
realize boom you know I don't want to be
woken up at 3:00 or to the right things
out yeah I loved it that he come lines
in hey were you dragged into the police
car naked yeah
and they show they wrestled you in civil
so the cops were dressed and you and you
were being naked by guys in cop uniforms
yeah and you were wrestling Wow I did
refused on principal you refused the
clothes you refused the clothes they
refused to wear clothes so your ass is
on the cop
yeah you found me you are a character
get me clothes that said that makes
y'all story look better right I said
this is very obviously that was mining
money that would have demanded clothes
Bravo my friend wrapping him up to take
him out yeah yeah so then and then when
you get down to the police station
you're nude and this would this was a
really cool little moment there was an
insane we're at the precinct there's the
hallway to go through the door and I'm
gonna no no man let's go let's go and
just like this this is how you found
I shouldn't be here anyway right Dada
Dada Dada da and this guy goes man
put these on man he had the plants with
that ham I had my number on him you know
and I was like no and he stopped me he
just took me on he goes
please man tomorrow you'll be really
happy I was like you know so you say
will you now stop playing the bongos in
the nude absolutely not
you